this video is brought to you by keeps
what's up wisecrack michael here now i'm
sure a lot of you are sick of hearing
about the oscars you either don't care
and are starting to wonder why you click
this video or you do care and are deeply
offended by the following statement
nobody should care about the Academy
Awards we say this as film lovers who
have been burned one too many times by
the Academy's bizarre choices and we say
it as philosophy students trying to
understand how crash could possibly be
considered the most significant film of
2004 you want cuz I'm right here I'm
trying to help you but most of all we
say it as human beings who hate the
media discourse surrounding the Oscars
so much we considered entering a sensory
deprivation tank for the duration of
this year's award season jokes aside
what's the big deal what's wrong with
people celebrating how much they love
Green Book and I'm about to embark on a
concert tour the majority of which will
be down south atlantic city no the deep
south the way we see it the problem lies
and the profound influence the Academy
Awards have on the creation of new
movies but we'll get there so without
further ado welcome to this wisecrack
edition the Oscars were a mistake but
before we get into it I want to give a
shout out to this week's sponsor keeps
keeps is a hair loss prevention
subscription service whose mission is to
help you keep your hair on top of your
head if you're a guy you should know
that two out of three men will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35 trust me
I would know if you love your locks then
you can combat this issue
no sweat keeps offers treatments that
can stop and even prevent hair loss
their treatments are FDA approved and
90% effective in most cases some men
even experience hair regrowth after
using their treatments going to the
doctor for this problem is
time-consuming and may not be your first
priority but keeps let you order your
own treatment from the comfort of your
own home and there is no doctor's visit
necessary find out why keeps has more
five-star reviews than any of its
competitors and why nearly 100,000 men
trust keeps as their hair loss
prevention medication keeps treatments
start at just $10 a month and for a
limited time you can get 50% off your
first order take action today and
prevent further hair
Godin keeps calm / wisecrack for 50% off
your first order that's K EEP s.com /
wisecrack now back to the show every
year tens of millions of people tuned in
to see who will receive the film
industry's highest honors but the
Academy that doles out oscars wasn't
just created to celebrate performances
by actors like Nicholas Cage in leaving
Las Vegas it was instead created to pay
people in the film industry less the
year is 1926 and your Louie be mayor an
MGM studio mogul preparing to do the
most studio mogul thing of all build a
fancy Santa Monica beach house as
recounted by critic and author David
Thompson and Vanity Fair Mayor wanted to
hire some MGM set designers helped
construct his Oceanside Paradise but
there was a problem the set designers
were just about to become a part of
Hollywood's first Union complete with
new contracts that made them very
expensive in case you were worried about
the well-being of there's new home he
managed by hiring a few pricey set
designers and relying on cheaper
laborers for the rest but the dude was
more or less haunted by the idea that
actors directors and screenwriters would
follow suit and unionize for better
wages so he concocted a genius plan
he made his own union he beat them to
the punch creating an institution that
could swoop up his opposition and stop
unions before they even started it was
the historical equivalent of your boss
giving you a gift card to your local TGI
Fridays instead of that raise you asked
for mayor's new institution was the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences the Academy for short if you
think the long name sounds snooty that's
the whole point
according to Thompson it made you think
the Academy had always been there
arranged by God and Harvard and Albert
Einstein and not a few cigar smoking
jerks looking for cheap non-union labor
at its inception the Academy was
comprised of 36 actors directors writers
technicians and producers they were
conferred elite status and the vague
promise that working conditions in the
industry would improve but while the
Academy promised to create industry
standards and handle labor disputes it
was privately viewed as a way to render
unions unnecessary on a broader level
the organization was dedicated to
promoting a positive wholesome image of
Hollywood there
a decade plagued by industry scandals in
the form of Charlie Chaplin and
scandalous divorce or fatty Arbuckle's
being tried for drunken manslaughter
anyway these powerful image conscious
folks had a fancy banquet in January of
1927 the only thing the festivities were
missing something to make people feel
even more special a legitimizing factor
if you will enter awards as mayor
accounted to his biographer I found that
the best way to handle movie makers was
to hang medals all over them if I got
them cups and awards they'd kill
themselves to produce what I wanted
that's why the Academy Award was created
come 1929 the first awards were handed
out in a 15 minute private ceremony
these awards were also a way for the
movie industry to affirm its own
artistic importance on one level this
can seem as obvious self-indulgence on
another level scholar Peter de tourny
argues it was a way to brand Hollywood
talent as skilled artistry rather than
labour in the process rendering labor
unions unnecessary dieter nee argues
that the award categories themselves
created two separate classes of
Hollywood workers lowly laborers and
artistes however mayor's ingenious
solution to the pesky union problem was
ultimately doomed the economic turmoil
of the early 1930s
led everyone from actors to writers to
directors to organize in a delicious
twist fledgling unions like the Screen
Actors Guild the Writers Guild and the
Directors Guild boycotted subsequent
Oscar ceremonies and successful attempts
to strong-arm the academy into
negotiations those unions remain
powerful to this day still that annual
love letter to Hollywood's most
glamorous residents would become one of
the most effective promotional tools of
all time establishing American film as
the world's primary form of
entertainment increasingly fawning media
coverage intensified America's emotional
investment in the movie industry and
especially in the celebrities who win
and lose shiny prizes as the cult of
celebrity grew obsessive interest in the
fashions worn the attractive dates
escorted and the scandalous
after-parties balloon so now we know the
shady origins of the Oscars but the real
question is are they even good at what
they do
after all if your goal is to award
artistic excellence you'd hope said
excellence would withstand the test of
time or at least do so better than say
the 1956
around the world in 80 days or the 1989
gem driving miss daisy' while an Oscar
award is pretty ubiquitously seen as a
confirmation of artistic merit some
decisions the Academy is made of casting
doubt on the industry's ability to
appraise its own work and that's putting
it politely this seemed like a better
idea in rehearsal last year alone
controversy brewed over choices like
best editing for Bohemian Rhapsody a
film which indieWIRE called
a masterclass and bad editing and which
even the editor himself admits of one
scene whenever I see it I want to put a
bag over my cup then there was the best
picture for Peter Farrelly's green book
which LA Times critic Justin Chang
succinctly called embarrassment the
matter of taste has haunted the oscars
from the very beginning with the
industry perpetually agonizing over its
desire to advance the art of filmmaking
and to spotlight commercial successes
we're going to focus on the history of
the Best Picture by the way because it
can help succinctly shine light on
larger issues in the Academy so
apologies to you best costume design
historians in its first year the Academy
straddled this line by awarding two best
pictures one went to the most
outstanding picture the commercially
successful World War one film wings and
one went to the most unique and artistic
picture the expressionist film sunrise a
song of two humans it created a division
between mainstream and artistic
excellence but then the Academy tweaked
things creating one ultimate Best
Picture category since then that award
has represented a tough balancing act
between entertainment value artisan ship
commercial success in the film
industry's public image all of which
must be reconciled when Hollywood
endorses one film as the definitive best
this has resulted in many questionable
choices in 1953 the still widely
respected films singing in the rain
wasn't even considered for Best Picture
the award instead went to the greatest
show on earth which has an abysmal 43%
critics score on Rotten Tomatoes the
wildly inventive film Brazil a wisecrack
favorite so maybe we're a little biased
also didn't manage to get nominated for
Best Picture in 1986 instead the top
prize went to out of Africa Brazil has a
98% critic approval on Rotten Tomatoes
and a 90% audience approval speaking to
its long lasting appeal and artistic
brilliance
meanwhile Out of Africa has a 58% critic
score and a not so bad 83% audience
score what
more gladiator won best picture in 2000
when the goddamn freaking matrix wasn't
even nominated I'm going to stop this
list before I burst a blood-vessel but I
think the question has been raised why
is the Academy proven to be both
predictable and frankly annoying in its
choice of Best Picture nominees and
winners there's a certain pattern when
it comes to the Oscars highest prize
most notably genre makes a big
difference for Best Picture Drama Center
rack up the top prize winning 89% of the
time between 1928 and 2010 according to
Collider specific types of drama also
have an easy way in a UCLA study of Best
Picture nominees between 1985 and 2009
found that war movies historical epics
and biographies fare incredibly well
meanwhile IMDB keywords like family
tragedy whistleblower domestic servant
and Watergate correlated most highly
with nominations Collider also noted
that the Oscar tends to go to the
longest film nominated and that 80% of
Best Picture winners since 1980 clocked
in at over two hours American film
historian Damien vana sums up the vibe
of the Best Picture winners as movies
that are aesthetically conservative but
which contain humanistic or uplifting
attitudes that is movies that make
Hollywood feel important without
challenging the status quo which is why
romantic war dramas like The English
Patient beat arguably better but
decidedly nihilistic films like Fargo so
what in contrast doesn't win Best
Picture negatively associated or IMDB
terms like zombie and black independent
film which is why the objectively
groundbreaking hasn't aged a day
Night of the Living Dead lost to the
decidedly dated musical Oliver and also
why Spike Lee didn't win an Oscar until
30 years after the release of do the
right thing which lost to and I can't
stress this enough Driving Miss Daisy oh
and if you're making a kickass fantasy
film or horror film don't hold your
breath waiting for a nomination after
all even psycho almost universally
regarded as the best horror film of all
time wasn't nominated for Best Picture
that was the same year flicks like Elmer
Gantry sons and lovers and the
sundowners none of what you've heard of
were nominated not even one of the
finest works of sci-fi is likely to earn
a nomination including the famously
snubbed breathtaking 2001 a space
in fact a sci-fi film has never won best
picture it might sound like we're
harping about all our favorite films
that didn't snag Best Picture
nominations but it's not just that the
list of films not giving Oscar nods
wouldn't be so objectionable if only so
many terrible or forgettable films
weren't lauded somewhat humorously the
status quo obsessed nature of the Oscars
can perhaps best be illustrated by a
decision made in 1929 the very first
feature-length talking picture was
disqualified for consideration because
it had an unfair advantage over silent
films the tendency for the Academy to
reward safe choices is only augmented by
their preferential voting system in
which voters rank nominees in order of
preference as a result films that are
less disliked tend to triumph over films
that are more polarizing innovative or
risky the industry's desire to
simultaneously seem important and
recognized commercially successful films
means that it tends to nominate
inspiring films based around popular
historical events and people Lincoln
even when those stories skew the facts
about historical figures or events
what's more those featuring actors who
transform physically into familiar
characters from history or literature
are also frequently rewarded whether
they're playing Freddie Mercury or
Winston Churchill or Queen Elizabeth
above all though naturally your film
must not ruffle the feathers of the
Academy which is why beloved provocative
films like American Psycho or tangerine
tend not to attract the same attention
as safe non paradigm-shifting films like
The King's Speech or frost/nixon it also
must not be seen as quote-unquote cheap
commercial fare like Back to the Future
and we'd be remiss not to point out that
a foreign language film has never won
Best Picture though we are rooting hard
for parasyte to change that in recent
decades Hollywood has attempted to make
itself more relevant by tweaking the
awards to recognize more popular films
they introduced a Best Animated Film
category in 2002 and expanded the Best
Picture category from 5 to 10 nominees
after the Dark Knight was infamously
smoked most notably the Academy proposed
reverting back to its original 1929
paradigm for the 2019 Oscars by
introducing an award for outstanding
achievement in popular film this
announcement ironically was quickly met
with outrage at the Academy's apparent
insinuation that I highly commercially
successful film couldn't also be the
best film of the year they quickly
rescinded the decision before promptly
and predictably
giving its highest honors to a
130-minute historically inaccurate drama
featuring an uplifting interracial
friendship during American segregation
speaking of greenbook important and
popular films that tend to win also seem
to skew preaching so that little temper
tantrum was it worth it hmm you never
win with violence Tony you only win when
you maintain your dignity dignity always
prevails without asking too many hard
questions or being too provocative so we
get a lot of feel-good interracial
friendships and a lot less horse people
fueled revolutions which gets us to
Oscar is a catch-all term for the way
studios try to game their way into a
Best Picture nomination
whether that be the kind of film they
make the time they release the film or
the marketing strategy surrounding them
Oscar bait can only exist because the
Oscars are so predictable for all the
previously cited reasons this mutually
reinforcing system means that Studios
keep making more English patients and
war horses and timing them to coincide
with the fall Oscar season while Oscar
bait existed as early as the 1930s it
really came into its dismal own when the
studio system was broken up this meant
that film studios no longer could
control movie theatres meaning they had
to more strategically plot to snag their
movies impressive theatrical runs
arguably the biggest breakthrough an
Oscar marketing came in 1978 with the
late December release of deer hunter the
film is great but Universal Studios
determined that it was too intense and
said to organically become a box-office
success so they planned its entire
marketing strategy around an Oscar
nomination spoiler alert the strategy
worked in deer hunter snagged in nine
nominations and five wins including Best
Picture in the process it changed the
way studio's thought about the awards
and so every fall we get a predictable
parade of movies about a world war or a
conflicted monarch or an inspiring
character overcoming the odds to succeed
because that's the gosh-darned American
Way and yes exceptions exist but it's an
undeniable trend along with the rise of
Oscar bait has come the intensification
of pre Oscar marketing campaigns now
Swain Academy judges with more than just
talent is as old as the Oscars
themselves when the awards were just a
year old Best Actress nominee Mary
Pickford had the entire voting committee
over for
she at her estate an invitation then
considered Tinseltown's greatest status
Emily she subsequently won her best
actress award but could victory really
have felt that great advertising
campaign soon extended beyond tea
parties with for your consideration ads
debuting newspapers in 1936 by 1955 the
film Marty boasted an Oscar budget of
$400,000 that was higher than its entire
production cost of three hundred and
forty three thousand dollars for this
effort the film won four little gold men
as we entered the new millennium
marketing had escalated to unprecedented
degrees asbahna notes all of which is to
say independent films like sorry to
bother you simply can't compete as boots
reilly explained on twitter that's even
if based on merit those films are just
as excellent and the films that do win
nominations or oscars get incomparable
boost in ticket sales and name brand
recognition even if they're called crash
so what is the mindless production
promotion and consumption of Oscar bait
films doing to the industry we'd argue
that over the past half-century it led
to a great many talented people
producing a great many not awesome films
with the conscious or subconscious goal
of winning a little gold man those
studio backed films then suck up nearly
all available press attention what that
inevitably means for a population with
only so much time and money to spend if
the movie theater is less attention and
less a claim for genuinely good and
provocative films that don't conform to
stodgy Oscar standards when you look
through the history of films that have
truly made the medium what it is today
you don't find a filmography of Oscar
Best Picture winners you find films that
were too daring to pander all of which
is to say skip the Oscars this year and
watch a couple of movies that aren't
afraid to alienate you try Brazil or
Spring Breakers advantageous or personal
shopper the which or under the Silver
Lake honestly anything but Green Book
today what do you think thanks to all
our patrons for supporting our podcasts
and the channel click that subscribe
button and as always thanks for watching
later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]